this week on brian ross investigates
profile in courage
my name is brian wallach at the age of
37
i was diagnosed with aos
four years later brian wallach has
defied the odds fighting the disease
that was supposed to be a death sentence
with his wife sandra leading a campaign
for a new law to get access to new
treatments and raise funds for research
on the rapidly progressive degenerative
disease
i say hi to you both
because they turn their pain
into purpose
even as the disease progresses he has
never given up sending messages of hope
every day on social media
our two daughters are my reason for
waking up every day
i'm really proud of what we've done i
did not
completely believe it was all possible
plus the one year anniversary of a very
dark day in american history more than
700 people have been charged with crimes
for their role in the attack on the
capitol and the fbi still looking for
more of them who knew what at the white
house and what did they do or failed to
do it's hard to imagine a more
significant and more serious dereliction
of duty
than that
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of media
height what a horrible
may have happened
so
sayonara
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with a profile in
courage the story of a young man
diagnosed with a disease that was
supposed to kill him years ago but brian
wallick and his wife sandra who are
related to me through my daughter-in-law
have as president biden said turn their
pain into purpose somehow finding a way
to get a bill through congress that
would speed up access to new treatments
and increase research into the crippling
disease that brian has been diagnosed
with als rhonda
that's right brian als is a particularly
cruel disease striking young people
without warning with rapid progression
robbing them of the ability to control
their physical functions but even with
the difficult prognosis brian wallock
he's just really confined to a
wheelchair his voice rapidly fading he's
helped to make an incredible impact in
finding a way to fight als
it was a death sentence
today
i consider myself
the luckiest man
on the face of the earth
als has long been known as the lou
gehrig disease named for the legendary
new york yankee who died from the fast
progressing neurodegenerative disease
two years after the diagnosis forced him
to retire from baseball
but brian wallick and his wife sandra
were not prepared to give up
veterans of democratic politics who met
on the campaign trail working for barack
obama it went on to white house jobs
they launched a campaign to increase
funding and research to cure the dreaded
disease
okay
and now because of the campaign they
launched there is new hope
president biden signed into law last
month legislation that would accelerate
access to new drugs and increase funding
for als research
the bill passed the senate unanimously
and the president praised brian and
sandra's courage and determination
the entire world was in front of them
perhaps a run for elective office home
in illinois at home in illinois
or working for this white house
raising two beautiful daughters
until everything changed
the coughs
the cramps the twitches
brian and saunder are joining us today
virtually
i say hi to you both
because they turn their pain
into purpose
to brian and saunder
to the patients and caregivers who built
and led this movement
thank you thank you thank you
and we're joined now by brian wallach
and his wife sandra abella thank you so
much for being here president biden said
you turned pain into purpose
[Music]
brian thank you so much for having us
it is a privilege to join you
[Music]
we were so
heartened by president biden's words
as we had spent the last two years
fighting for a bill
it will give every als patient
[Music]
where there was previously
no hope
and brian and sandra you know what is
the prognosis now for for brian for you
brian
well today i have actually outlived my
prognosis when i was diagnosed i was
told to expect to live six months today
the average als patient lives two to
five years so of the patients who were
diagnosed the same year as me in 2017 80
percent
have passed away
so i am one of the lucky ones and i plan
to keep going
for as long as i can
even as the disease has restricted brian
physically he is active every day
sending messages of hope on social media
posting videos of himself at his
daughter's school events just a dad he
wrote and this video on the way home
from picking up his daughters at school
as it began to rain
here's to rainbow umbrellas kindness and
to those moments each day he wrote where
you can't help but enjoy this life
i'm incredibly proud of brian um
i'm really proud of what we've done i
did not
completely believe it was all possible
and so
brian has inspired that belief in um
more being possible even
um with his own spouse
so
um it certainly though to your point
brian is it's very hard um having this
disease is extremely challenging so
one thing we have been so focused on is
how do we better support
the als community so that they have what
they need to both take care of
themselves with respect to the disease
and then have the energy
and the capability to mobilize and drive
this grassroots effort that has been
the remarkable result of this movement
for the last several years
and it seems your two daughters are part
of the battle part of the campaign
they sure are
what we've realized
[Music]
is it a diagnosis like also
[Music]
everyone's involved in the fight
and
our two daughters
[Music]
of inspiration
to fight this thing
i want to thank you both for being here
and uh
just hats off to you for the campaign
and the
face of incredible obstacles you've done
so much and you've shown that things can
get done in washington if there's a will
well brian thank you for having us
[Music]
and thank you for shining a light on
this fight
it means everything to us
thank you for being here tonight
brian wallach's social media messages
are both heartwarming and heartbreaking
he's worth following on twitter at brian
wallick up next a day that we might want
to forget but definitely should not the
attack on the capitol one year ago and
what happens next
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury bonus
and welcome back it's been a full year
now since the u.s capitol was attacked
by a mob that sought to delay or upset
the certification of joe biden as
president in render we are learning more
every day about what was and was not
done to stop it
that's right brian
the house select committee investigating
january 6 has interviewed hundreds of
witnesses made criminal referrals on two
people who have refused to testify
trump adviser steve bannon and former
chief of staff mark meadows
and they have unearthed thousands of
emails and text messages that continue
to raise questions about president trump
what republican congresswoman liz chaney
has called a dereliction of duty brian
that's right so to learn more about what
is to come in this investigation we're
joined now by mia bloom a professor at
georgia state university and a fellow at
new america's international security
program and author of pastels and
pedophiles inside the mine of q
and from washington d.c tonight retired
fbi agent brad garrett also a consultant
for abc news and brad garrett let me
start with you more than 700 people have
been charged but the fbi says it's still
looking for people based on the photos
the videos they took of themselves as
they ransacked the capital
so brian one of the problems obviously
is that no one was really arrested at
the scene
so you're playing catch-up basically for
the last year now a large number of the
people that they have id'd is through
tips
people see them on television they see
fbi posters and they go oh that's my
neighbor that's my aunt that's my uncle
i mean maybe some folks have even turned
in their own children
so you have that side of it the other is
going to be cell phones what they did
was they pulled all the cell phone
traffic in or around the capitol on
january 6th and through that they were
able to id people
but the 300 plus left i think the issue
is
maybe they know who they are but they
don't really know yet
and so they've got a lot of work ahead
of them
and mia bloom let me ask you who are
these people not all of them are big
fish or members of extremist groups or
are they
well no not all of them are members of
extremist groups according to the data
that's being collected by a number of my
colleagues either at the university of
maryland or at the university of chicago
about 20 percent have a criminal record
but we do see quite a number of these
people that are affiliated with
anti-government militias or with groups
like the oath keepers and the three
percenters including the first two
trials that we will see at the end of
february one person being a
self-proclaimed militia person and the
other um is from texas and owen schroer
he is a three percenter so
we do see some overlap between the far
right and the people who were at the
capitol but there were also tons of
regular people grandmothers and students
and people who thought this was like a
vacation for them so really we don't
have a profile
we just have a lot of different people
converged that day and so brad garrett a
question for you from rhonda schwartz
rhonda
and brad what are the lessons learned
for law enforcement from all this
looking back now
uh what what have we learned about could
this happen again and how could it be
handled better
well let's start with it certainly could
happen again
but you know the real issue is if you
have
really good corroborated intelligence
then you need to act on it i mean the
fbi had information dhsn information i'm
talking about people talking about how
do you smuggle guns into the capitol
uh
who are we going to quote unquote arrest
once we get inside the capitol where are
we going to rendezvous in caravans and
come in and go out of the capital i mean
there's just unbelievable amount of
information
and then you know you lay on top of that
there you know the motivation obviously
by former president trump and others
that they should be there and
legitimizing their behavior there
and so
the real question lies
will we have anything tomorrow of course
i don't really know
uh are the capitol police better
prepared yes
but
if you had intelligence like you had one
year ago
and you have the same
number of people in riot gear and
available immediately you it could
happen again i presume they don't have
that kind of information i haven't seen
fences go up we'll have to see what the
profile of physical security looks like
in the morning here
but
you know you have to listen to people
one of the big faults apparently
according to recent reports is the
intelligence community didn't share with
each other i don't think that's actually
accurate i think the information was
there
and for whatever reason the capitol
police chose not to act on it now again
politics could be right in the middle of
this where they were told to act and do
a certain way that remains to be seen
mia bloom let me ask you one of the
remarkable things you were telling us
was that the role of women which has not
received much attention was actually
quite substantial
it was very important it was very
important in terms of the organization
on social media
organizing the buses that took people to
the capitol paying for hotels in fact
when you look at the first person shot
ashley babbitt became a martyr for the
maga cause but there was another woman
killed that day roseanne boylan who is
the subject of um podcasts by
msnbc i'm in mohammedin so we understand
that women played a very important role
in terms of the connective tissue
linking the different groups together as
well as the fact that you know the women
were the ones being able to promote this
idea that you know you need to do this
you need to step up it reminds me a lot
of the way that the jihadis encouraged
men to go join the jihad in afghanistan
and syria but i think we have to
understand that you know
if there if nothing really happens as a
result of january 6 and i think merrick
garland's speech today indicates that
there will be consequences then last
year was a dry run for 2024 and so we
have to be very careful maybe less so
tomorrow but we have to be vigilant for
future
attempts to undermine the election
indeed well thank you very much mia
bloom and retired fbi agent brad garrett
much more to learn much more to come on
this story coming up next here this
week's winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin the editor-in-chief of
media which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the abrams media
group in aiden we begin with your choice
for the winner which surprised me the
cnn new year's eve team of anderson
cooper and an apparently quite
inebriated andy cohen who delivered a
belittling farewell to outgoing mayor
of new york city bill de blasio
after four years
as the mayor of new york
the only thing
that democrats and republicans can agree
on
is what a horrible
mayor has been
so
sayonara sucka
wow 2022.
i mean it's a new year
all right aidan tell us why that was a
media winner
so just for the record andy cohen has
been defending himself he said that he's
not going to apologize for getting a
little uh inebriated on new year's eve
which i think is a sentiment we can all
uh agree with uh the reason that they
were named winner is just because of the
rating um cnn's new year's eve special
which took place in times square it was
the most watched event on cable news in
america uh in 2022. um so it started at
8 p.m it ran over five hours just the
portion with andy cohen and anderson
cooper and it averaged 2.12 million
viewers over the course of that time uh
in the demo which as you know brian is
the sort of advertiser coveted age
demographic they drew almost 800 000
viewers which is really a staggering
amount for cable news right now
particularly at that hour it's also a
huge amount for cnn and was cnn's most
watch event in month um it also meant
that the network beat out fox news uh
and msnbc in the ratings for the show
which is a big deal because the network
has had a pretty rocky 2021 in the
ratings
it beat fox news in january for the
first time in years but then sunk down
to third place for the rest of the year
as fox news surged back uh to first um
so the show had plenty of highlights um
you know a little bit of controversy but
ultimately really good ratings and
that's why they were winner
this is the road to success for jeff
zucker now and his cnn ratings issues
you know i think it's a typical cnn
rating story uh when they have big
events like this that are sort of must
watch everyone turns to cnn they have
that with breaking news that's why
january they had such high ratings it
was because of the end of the trump
administration and the riot at the
capitol um when you go down to weeks
that do not have big events or big news
cycles cnn drops the third behind fox
news and msnbc um but it's really for
big events like these that everyone
tuned to cnn and jeff sucker's really
good at making those shows happen
well that was quite a show to watch
that's for sure now let's turn to this
week's loser sean hannity at fox news
why sean hannity aiden
that's right so the house select
committee which is investigating the
january 6 riot at the capitol published
a letter that they sent to the fox news
host requesting his cooperation in their
investigation
now the committee says they're in
possession of thousands of documents uh
including a trove of information uh that
was given to them by former trump chief
of staff mark meadows now in that trove
of documents are texts that sean hannity
sent to mark meadows around january 6
and they published a few of those in
that new letter
one of them uh was sean handy warning
the trump administration that things
could get ugly right before january 6.
another one said that was which was sent
after january 6 urged the trump
administration to not mention the
election ever again now what's so
stunning about this message is that it
displays on the part of sean hannity a
real understanding that trump's lies
about the 2020 election are dangerous
and directly resulted in the riot at the
capitol and i suppose you have to give
him credit for that on the other hand
what's disappointing is that in the
years since on air sean hannity has
declined to tell his viewers that their
trump bears any responsibility for the
violence that happened that day and in
fact has continued to propagate this
idea that there were um you know uh
problems with the last election um and
that it should be looked at and that
trump was hard done by by it so you know
sean hannity revealing in private that
he had concerns about what was happening
that day going on air and not saying
that there was any connection between
the riot and president donald trump um
that's a real problem for him and so
quickly in 15 seconds what about the
first amendment issue here of congress
trying to get testimony from a reporter
well i think that's an issue as well and
that's certainly how sean hannity is
going to fight it so far he has not
commented publicly about this neither
has fox news they have not responded to
any of our requests for comment um so
we'll see how what their strategy is
going to be to combat this but i have a
feeling he's going to cooperate at the
end of the day all right aidan
mclaughlin the editor in chief of media
thank you very much for being here and
welcome to our program for the year and
that is our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week on the law on crime trial
network
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you